little did I know that I ended up with
everyone I needed to be in my life it
was it just I think I felt safe and
that's a really hard thing for me to
feel
and I know that you guys love me for me
I'm starting I'm not kidding
tissue please Selena Gomez emotional as
she reunites with her Wizards of Waverly
Place co-stars as I hear people say all
the time and cannot spell touche the
actors joins Jennifer Stone AKA Harper
her on-screen bestie and David de Louise
who played Jerry her on-screen dad on
their Wizards of Waverly pod where they
look back on the Disney series I have a
little sister and she's nine so she's
fallen in love with the show and I even
before she was born sometimes I would be
by myself and I would just throw on an
episode to fall asleep too
um who's loved it who's her favorite
character
oh I don't know she has one because she
gets mad at my character a lot Selena of
course played Alex Russo on the show
from 2007 to 2012. so you're telling me
that I have to come up with a solution
all by myself to a problem that I
created all by myself
well that's not fair
she's the one always getting in trouble
of the family she uses magic to get out
of situations and she's the one
definitely using it to get her brothers
in trouble and she's the rebel of the
family you guys genuinely loved me and I
that's all I could have asked for the
unconditional trust and bond we had I
miss so much I'm starting I'm not
kidding
tissue please cell tears up sharing just
how much that time meant to her I can't
begin to tell you guys without making it
such a little cry session I just
I I felt
I felt like I was the happiest I'd been
my whole life and that's I don't want
that to be a sad thought because I'm
really grateful and happy I recognize
that obviously it's because I have this
different
attention on me that I just didn't have
then and that was a really pure time we
have such a family on our show and I
enjoy it I mean getting up every day
making kids laugh is the best feeling in
the whole world but despite how close
the cast was while filming Selena says
they lost touch which she admits is her
biggest regret you're gonna make me cry
come on I think I slowly became
like kind of shamed like I felt ashamed
of the the decisions that I made and I
didn't want you guys to see me in the
state that I was in
because a you would have told me the
truth which terrifies me and B
I I didn't want to let you down I only
know how to be myself and when I combat
it with all of who I am it always try
like trumps everything since Wizards of
Waverly Place ended a decade ago
Selena's become a superstar there's her
critically acclaimed role on only
murders in the building
he lied to me and I'm not leaving here
until you tell me why her chart topping
success is a singer
[Music]
and then there's rare Beauty her hugely
popular Cosmetics line
[Music]
but Stella says even all that success
can't come close to how she felt during
that magical time on Wizards I'm so
lucky and grateful that I get to be a
part of all these other projects but I'm
I'm I tell people all the time I've
never had that feeling that I've had
with the whole Wizards crew
foreign